est-ce que ce spectacle il devait avoir
lieu ou pas Jean-Marie
mais elle est elle est indestructible
chez les crabouille bouge encore
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
elle est terrifiante et bien surtout
comment elle aurait avalé comme j'ai ma
grand-mère alors avalé un chat la queue
lui sortirait encore par la bouche elle
dirait que c'est pas elle va donc
je vais te montrer la vidéo et elle m'a
rappelé mon skate je l'exorciste il y a
eu un moment j'ai envie de lui dire
arrête de hurler que ma mère suce des
[ __ ] en enfer
[Musique]
elle était au Monoprix mais bon
Jean-Marie est-ce que non mais est-ce
que vous êtes vous êtes vu avec
Dieudonné vous êtes parlé ou pas du tout
nous c'est parler bien sûr il y a
plusieurs mois et vous avez dit ça fait
un spectacle tous les deux vous vouliez
faire un spectacle idée de départ
c'était moi j'adore relever les défis
qui me et à l'image d'ailleurs de Bruno
Gaccio qui avait des
qui avait fait un livre avec Dieudonné
qui quelque part moi j'ai voulu aussi je
me suis dit si je saurai si par un
énorme grand pardon à genoux
on arrivait à remettre sur scène
donc c'était quoi cet spectacle de
pardon oui vraiment pardon pas grand
pardon ça fait un peu trop un peu trop
mais c'était vraiment l'idée de départ
d'ailleurs l'idée de départ je fais à
dire c'est moi qui l'avais trouvé ça
c'était deux cercueils et on était mort
d'accord et des cercueils souverains
et se retrouver en face de Dieu quoi
enfin on avait la voix de Dieu d'accord
que ne disait bon alors
allez-y je suis chez vous quoi alors
Dieudonné
l'idée c'était de le rattraper un mec
qui dort sa catégorie et pratiquement le
plus drôle de nous tous et ça personne
ne conteste tu vois et donc c'était un
brûlot c'était un c'était le cœur du
réacteur d'une centrale nucléaire donc
petit à petit je me suis rendu compte
que ça allait pas être jouable vous
l'avez écrit le spectacle pardon vous
l'avez écrit le spectacle non non j'ai
vu deux fois en tout cas
donc ils ont journée lieu à des trucs
qu'on voulait on allait avoir en plus du
clafoutis une fatwa sûrement au cube
puisque le spectacle des marais on était
on avait été tués par un terroriste qui
s'est fait exploser tu vois et donc le
tout était traité d'une manière très
très drôle mais bon les jours sont
passés Dieudonné il est parti
en vacances donc et
en arrière petit à petit je me suis dit
d'un autre côté de garde du corps pour
les enfants à l'école
tu vois tous mes amis ma belle famille
et juive ça n'a rien à voir d'ailleurs
mais je me suis dit quoi ils t'ont dit
quoi autant tu vois pour le Stade de
France Stade de France tout le monde m'a
dit ne le fais pas tu vas te viander ça
va être la fin
je vais quand même le faire mais là
les arguments étaient très forts et puis
j'avais mon Laurent Baffie qui me dit
c'est impossible moi vivant je je verrai
pas ça Laurent Ruquier aussi d'ailleurs
qui m'a défendu de manière
extraordinaire à la fois où la alors
justement
[Musique]
de grosses rien de [ __ ]
c'est quoi les arguments bah c'est ce
que je viens de t'expliquer je peux te
les répéter
tu vas pas faire un spectacle avec
Dieudonné mais quand tu leur expliquais
que c'est un spectacle de repentance il
disait quoi oui c'est c'est mais je
crois que c'est pas possible j'ai relu
j'ai relu de c'est la Bible
m'amuse à la lire parce que tu trouves
tout quoi dedans et il y a un moment
Jésus dit
aux voleurs c'est mieux
je sais que tu veux le rap plus jamais
de ta vie tu vois mais le mieux c'est
que tu partes parce que pour tout le
monde
tu seras toujours
un voleur et j'ai relu et relu et relu
cette phrase et je me suis dit pas il y
a pas tellement de de pardon à obtenir
il y a rien à gagner il y a que des
énormes coups à prendre et ma conscience
et ma femme qui est pas loin elle est
toujours un peu à côté et m'ont dit mais
je suis impossible que tu
si tu veux ce mélange était impossible
alors
il y a cette productrice Christelle
Camus qui dit être la productrice la
productrice du spectacle que vous avez
signé un contrat ensemble elle t'a
laissé une vidéo je l'ai pas vu la vidéo
alors un message à tout passer
Jean-Marie je te jure voilà je découvre
la vidéo comme toi on va voir ce qu'elle
est ce qu'elle dit Christelle
Jean-Marie bonjour j'ai un petit message
pour toi bon ben tu sais que le public
on t'attend tous pour le 29 novembre au
Summum de Grenoble comme tu le sais j'ai
pas lancé enfin on n'a pas parce qu'il y
a plusieurs productions on n'a pas lancé
bien entendu de procédure contre toi
parce que tu avais peur de perdre tes
contrats avec Laurent Ruquier et
d'autres projets à venir et comme tu
avais dit de toute façon à notre cher
ami Élie Semoun que tu étais un bouffon
avec des couilles et vu que tu as
toujours dit que tu avais des coups et
tu les as toujours montré et bien écoute
on se donne rendez-vous le 29 novembre
au saumon de Grenoble et bien évidemment
que ce n'est inimaginable si tu ne
venais pas tu imagines le public déjà un
serait très déçu dirait qu'effectivement
tu n'as pas de couilles alors que tu
fais la morale à Élie Semoun et puis on
partirait avec plusieurs productions en
procédure par rapport au contrat que tu
as signé et dans les avenants que tu as
signé donc j'espère honnêtement qu'on en
arrivera pas là parce que mon métier
c'est pas de faire le procès aux
artistes c'est de les produire sur scène
si tu venais pas parce qu'en cas où tu
es pris en otage par des extraterrestres
à la dernière minute t'inquiète pas on
fera quand même le spectacle en tournée
voilà alors voilà c'était le sur les
contrats évidemment il n'existe plus
vraiment il y a strictement plus aucun
contact aucun contrat un état la barre
d'aucun navire elle n'est strictement
plus rien elle est vaporisée elle
continue à penser qu'elle a des sociétés
tuer les distribue les récompenses et
les disgr alors
la reine et mettre vous allez nous
répondre là dessus regardez sur
spectacle il va se passer quoi bon
Jean-Marie ben si Jean-Marie
effectivement effectivement alors c'est
pas qu'à moi parce que ça implique
c'est une affaire de plus de enfin moi
je parle pour entre les sociétés que je
représente ça peut monter jusqu'à 10
millions d'euros parce qu'il n'a pas oui
il n'y a pas que ma société
alors un petit détail allez monter à
1400000 4 millions assez vite Dardar
vous allez bien dans l'école Gambin elle
change de braquet et hopel [ __ ] et
puis elle est quand même arrivée à 14
millions le premier chiffre alors moi je
lui dis Christelle 14 millions d'euros
il va falloir dans la mesure où tu vas
te les prendre dans le cul
il faut que tu les roules bien bien bien
roulé parce que tu vas t'abîmer le trou
de balle
[Applaudissements]
parce que il y a Christelle qui dit de
vous mettre elle dit vous êtes vous êtes
son avocat cherche à se faire connaître
mais ne connaît aucun contenu des
contrats comment un avocat peut parler
des contrats de Jean-Marie Bigard sans
les avoir mdr elle vous dit elle vous
pose la question elle dit vous n'avez
pas les contrats écoutez j'ai pas
l'habitude alors ces deux salles de
ambiance
mais là je crois que ce soir je vais
faire une exception oui alors dites nous
écoutez cette dame a monté une société
de production dans les années 2010 2012
elle dépose le bilan j'ai faillite
elle est sur le carreau x milliers
d'euros et des créanciers elle remonte
une société
la société est en dépôt de bilan elle
est en faillite et au moment où elle
signe des contrats avec Jean-Marie
Bigard et d'autres ça signature de vos
plus rien parce qu'elle est en faillite
il y a un liquidateur derrière qui est à
Draguignan qui s'appelle maître Lucas et
qui n'en peut plus
il en peut plus il est assailli de
réclamation il est assailli de coups de
téléphone il sait plus où il met la tête
parce qu'effectivement elle a menti à
tout le monde elle est liquidée sur le
plan judiciaire donc Jean-Marie tu n'as
rien signé avec elle ça vous convient et
même encore
tout devient caduc c'est-à-dire que par
exemple l'OSE ça faut vraiment là j'ai
toujours dit qu'elle avait des couilles
mais là elle en a plus que moi
c'est-à-dire elle dit qu'elle n'a jamais
reçu d'avance je vais jouer moi
Jean-Marie Bigard je suis là dimanche 18
à 18h je suis au festival de Couvrot
cette date qui avait été prévues par
ailleurs avec David Hardy mon ancien
producteur nous allons le faire elle
hurle
les cheveux roux comme ça TOI et elle
dit si vous faites ça vous aurez 80000
18 millions enfin bon elle a rajouté un
zéro à chaque fois qu'elle prononce le
chiffre tu vois et elle nie avoir reçu
donc des avances parce que les gens qui
ont prévu des spectacles avec moi ont
donné des avances avec la productrice
agresser Le Camus nous avons avec Maître
Ludo nous avons
qui précise que telle date à telle heure
telle date à telle heure telle date à
telle heure par exemple pour le festival
de couvreau elle a reçu 2000 2005
900 euros d'avance
venir devant les médias en disant je
n'ai rien reçu Monsieur Bigard va de
ce qu'il
n'a pas c'est pas mal tu as une dette tu
l'as fait rembourser par un autre mais
comment elle sort les 14 millions
d'euros doit le sort d'où ce chiffre ben
moi j'ai économise petit à petit mais là
pour l'instant
je le vois je la vois mal barré donc
c'était ta productrice ou pas un moment
c'était ta productrice un moment mais
elle a été le se comporter comme tel
d'accord mais en fait elle ne l'était
pas puisque de dès le départ elle n'a
aucune licence pour produire des
spectacles une pauvre licence des deux
qui lui permet même pas de produire des
spectacles c'est-à-dire c'est infernal
de voir la plomb de cette femme parce
que tu sais que tu es une femme tu
répète tout le temps la même chose avec
les mêmes mots tu vois apparemment même
le mec le plus serein il se dit attends
est-ce que je sais pas j'étais obligé de
payer quoi il y a un moment tu dis bah
moi je je marche dans la rue en
regardant derrière moi
pour voir tu paieras rien hein tu vas
pas faire le spectacle mais non mais il
va faire le spectacle
du haut avec Dieudonné donc non non
faut surtout dire à tous les gens qui
nous regarde il sera là tous ceux qui
ont payé leur place se fassent le plus
vite possible fasse une demande se
mettre peut-être ensemble ce groupe et
pour dire on veut récupérer notre argent
parce que est-ce qu'elle est en train de
dire c'est que elle a vendu des places
énormément de pas ce que ça cartonné
tout de suite elle a vendu tout de suite
elle nous a dit je suis plus tranquille
place
maintenant voilà donc
ça fait deux secondes se fait 2 millions
2 millions d'euros elle a pu les vendre
des places elle les a vendues alors
qu'il n'avait pas le droit de les vendre
d'accord rappelle qu'elle est en
faillite donc là donc là elle aurait
encaissé 2 millions 200000 euros bah
d'après elle en tout cas c'est pas sûr
que le chiffre soit exact mais en tout
cas d'après nous avait été obligé de
rembourser sûr
elle va on attend fièvreusement parce
que tu vois normalement pour un quidam
ici sur ce plateau il fait un truc
pareil
ils viennent ils te mettent en garde à
vue et puis te saisissent et bien ils
viennent évaluer ta télé le piano des
gosses alors le machin je fais ce que
j'ai dans ma maison j'ai pas grand-chose
le reste c'est du Ikea c'est c'est pas
cher mais Jean-Marie elle a parlé aussi
dans d'autres trucs elle a fait des
révélations euh ici elle a pas
uniquement révélé les problèmes tes
problèmes voilà c'est 14 millions
d'euros elle a également fait des
révélations sur votre état de santé sur
ton état de santé celui de Dieudonné
que c'est leur dernier spectacle et ce
que vous nous dites
autrement je dirais pas ça mais bien sûr
68 ans il a quand même moi ça fait
longtemps que je travaille avec
Jean-Marie je suis la femme de l'ombre
donc c'est vrai que je ne viens pas
forcément sur les plateaux accompagnés
les artistes mais il a un diabète très
élevé il a une polyarthrite qui est très
élevée aussi et il a des problèmes de
cœur moi j'ai eu il y a 4 ans des
spectacles ont été annulés parce qu'il
nous avait fait des des AVC sur scène et
ça si Jean-Marie vient demain c'est
dommage qu'il ne soit pas présent alors
qu'est-ce que des AVC j'en ai fait un
une fois c'est un centre de la France et
il a vu le regard que lui portait
Laurent j'ai adoré que tu lui dis faut
pas me tutoyer nous ne sommes pas des
amis et elle a fait une réponse du genre
Messi tu sais c'était vu à la foire du
trône il y a 18 ans
on avait acheté papa tu étais à côté de
moi
[Applaudissements]
c'est incroyable incroyable donc tout ça
c'est n'importe quoi c'est n'importe
quoi c'est du c'est du vent du début à
la fin j'attends j'attends je dis
j'appelle je fais chier maître Ludo
trois fois par jour en disant c'est
quand c'est quand que on arrive chez
elle et que on lui dit Madame Camus vous
êtes en garde à vue alors parce que vous
avez volé de l'argent et à beaucoup de
gens et des sommes énormes tu vois et
c'est pas monsieur Bigard c'est pas JMB
production qui a reçu les avances c'est
vous madame Camus on a vos trois contes
on a la date et l'heure à la minute près
vous avez reçu sur vos comptes
personnels les avances il faut les
rendre alors lui expliquer qu'elle doit
rendre l'argent parce qu'elle est un
petit peu hypnotisée sur l'idée alors je
garde tout alors elle dit
alors elle réagit sur les réseaux elle
met un avocat qui vient sur scène pour
parler de nos contrats sans avoir vu nos
contraintes extraordinaire d'où il sort
celui-là donc en parlons de vous
les deux tu sors
je suis pas en état de en état de
faillite je vais très bien
je connaisse je voulais c'est le genre
de personne qui est intéressant sur le
plan psychiatrique c'est vrai il y a un
problème pathologique chez elle c'est à
dire que elle est poursuit de toute part
il y a des plaintes de toutes parts il
le procureur s'intéresse à elle le
liquidateur la poursuit mais malgré cela
elle fait comme si elle était une autre
personne c'est-à-dire elle a un
dédoublement de personnes alors moi je
suis pas psy mais je veux dire que le
cas est intéressant alors elle elle dit
il y a quelqu'un qui a dit vous allez
devoir en rembourser des places elle dit
non car l'artiste doit être absent de 30
minutes de sa prestation la 20 minutes
absent pas de remboursement c'est quoi
cette histoire
de ce qu'elle dit c'est n'importe quoi
mais pas petite histoire pour montrer
son grand cœur je fais un gars une
prestation gratuite pour les enfants du
ciel les enfants du ciel c'est s'occupe
de ça c'est la directrice avec son mari
me suit un peu son nom pardon c'est pour
les gens qui ont perdu un enfant ou que
la médecine n'a pas réussi à sauver tu
vois et donc c'est pour venir en aide à
ces gens-là elle dit si vous faites si
vous recevez Jean-Marie Bigard je vais
vous demander 80
000 euros elle a pas peur avec les 0
hein on y va ah ouais dès qu'elle veut
faire peur elle rajoute 4-0 tu vois et
elle et elle a donc elle est toute seule
dans son monde et j'ai un espèce de
sentiment d'impuissance qui m'empêche de
elle me dit dormir quoi elle me dit que
vous allez devoir payer les 14 millions
d'euros
démord pas que le 29 novembre oui vous
serez serez à côté de Dieudonné pour
faire un beau spectacle qui n'est ni
écrit ni accepté par moi et elle
continue à montrer ma tête
et mon nom en vendant des places alors
extraordinaire qu'est-ce qui va se
passer le 29 novembre alors hein
qu'est-ce qui va se passer le 29
novembre Dieudonné va faire un spectacle
quand même
a priori elle a raison comment
j'ai fait j'ai signé par mon autre
avocate un protocole d'accord
qui demandait à donner il a accepté tout
de suite
de ne pas d'arrêter de communiquer mon
image ma tête est de vendre des places
en mon nom donc lui il a tout cessé
quand même normal on peut dire ce qu'on
veut de lui mais ça n'est pas un cas
pathologique c'est-à-dire lui il a cessé
immédiatement les affiches sur son site
sur
quand vous dites quand vous dites que
Dieudonné mine de rien il est normal
c'est Gilles multiples condamnations
quand même pour un juif antisémite
même avant il y en a énormément
énormément
avec lui ça peut déjà être un débat
quand même
après tout ça c'était bien après tout ce
qui s'est passé vous lui lui il a sifflé
la fin du match
elle mais il est dans quel état d'esprit
de donner aujourd'hui mais dans la
quatrième mi-temps mon mari c'est pas
logique parce que si elle vous demande
de l'argent à vous et pas à lui puisque
le spectacle s'arrête
vous ne le savez pas mais c'est toujours
la productrice de Dieudonnée que il est
en train de découvrir le poteau rose il
est en train d'atterrir donc elle se sa
productrice c'était j'espère elle était
alors Jean-Marie si c'est pas vrai
c'est que je suis libre comme le vent
d'aller à couvreau dimanche à 18
dimanche 18h je serai là les gens je
prépare un spectacle je peux pas savoir
avec donc comme tu le sais
Laurent Ruquier Laurent Baffie et que je
cite aussi évidemment
Arnaud le mort bien sûr ça va bien avec
moi parce que moi je n'arrête pas de
mourir en ce moment je suis mort le 23
août d'après les médias donc je suis
mort et là Ici Paris à 3 jours la
couverture
Jean-Marie Bigard
foudroyé par un AVC j'ai peur que je
mets 203 et tout il va finir par avoir
raison ça se relever mourir en prenant
une tuile sur la tête j'en sais rien
mais
donc moi je vais très bien je suis très
très loin de faire un AVC je suis en
plein régime au prochain spectacle j'ai
trouvé grâce alors Enrique le moyen de
hurler parce que les gens adorent quand
je hurle tu vois j'ai trouvé le moyen de
hurler des détails de la vie
qu'on a tous et quand je vais dire moi
j'ai décroché j'ai décroché j'étais à
deux paquets de conneries par jour j'ai
décroché j'ai replongé deux trois fois
j'ai replongé j'avais dit la politique
jamais puis Sarkozy me dit je vous
emmène au Vatican
du coup j'ai pris mon appareil photo
j'ai dit je fais peut-être ramener des
bons souvenirs tu vois et puis je vais
parler avec le Saint Père tous les deux
on est un peu collègue parce que lui
aussi fait des stades et donc on a parlé
un petit peu que ça donc ça démarre
comme ça entre nous donc maintenant mais
Jean-Marie tu regrettes ce que tu as dit
sur Agnès Buzin ou pas du tout
parce que on en parlait avec Laurent la
dernière fois alors
à ne pas reprocher Agnès Buzin dont le
mari
et l'ennemi juré du professeur Raoult
j'ai beaucoup de mal
à dire cette femme vous avez mis
un médicament peut-être qu'il ne vous
plaisait pas peut-être qu'il ne plaisait
pas à l'ensemble de du conseil
scientifique mais c'est un gars qui
voulait essayer un truc et ce médicament
utilisé par 2 milliards de personnes
depuis 70 ans vous l'avez mis au rang
des médicaments vénéneux et de par sa
position elle a fait là un abus de
pouvoir énorme et elle se coule douce
maintenant en Suisse et ça m'ennuie un
petit peu mais donc quand tu dis que
quand tu dis que tu as fait des
conneries tout ça
je dirais elle elle a fait des conneries
mais c'est une professionnelle
donc moi j'ai pas bu lutter toi tu
considères
[Musique]
que tu as fait beaucoup de conneries
aujourd'hui ou pas écoute que j'arrive
dans une boulangerie je demande une
baguette bien cuite tout le monde se
retourne en disant ah Bigard et je leur
dis tiens j'aurais encore dû faire mes
ma gueule
effectivement on repère parce que j'ai
une grosse voix et puis que j'y vais pas
avec le dos de la cuillère et très
souvent j'ai tort ma femme est venue ici
pour le dire et vous l'avez d'ailleurs
salué et elle vous adore à nous aussi
sérieusement on l'a donné les pires
comme Gilles
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
parce que regarde tu vois je vais voir
je vais te montrer l'extrait de François
Cluzet il en a rajouté une couche encore
voilà et c'est vrai que tu dis que tu
avais des conneries il y a plein de gens
t'envoles un peu il a comme moi je suis
comme Laurent Ruquier comme Laurent elle
a dit c'est vrai que Jean-Marie voilà on
t'aime quoi qu'il arrive
bois quelque chose oui bien sûr
regardez
nous foutent dans une humeur de doute
regardez ce qui s'est passé avec les
antivens avec tout ça je ça remets en
cause les attaques de New York enfin
c'est pas possible enfin il y a eu 3000
morts enfin quand même c'est 3000 fois
la personne qui dit ça donc oui il y a
une forme de collaboration d'un pays en
paix et on se met à douter et puis ils
ont une influence donc je crois qu'il
faut faire très attention même moi qui
dit quand même beaucoup de conneries je
me dois le faire attention à ce que je
dis alors voilà et c'est vrai qu'il
avait parlé de toi avant voilà c'est pas
grave si je croise un jour je dirais
mais ferme ta gueule mais ferme ta
gueule mais ferme ta gueule
ferme ta gueule
[Applaudissements]
Jean-Marie tu disais au début de
l'intervention que Dieudonné était pour
toi le plus drôle c'est vrai que c'est
la vie de de nombreuses personnes qui me
regardent aussi mais qui lui il a fait
voilà il a été trop loin donc tu pouvais
pas faire un spectacle avec lui pour toi
il était trop loin il y avait plus moyen
de revenir en arrière non non tout d'un
coup tu vois énormément de gens me
disent c'est pas possible de faire
monter sur scène fortissons par exemple
tu vois ça c'est pas jouable
j'ai vu deux fois ensuite il est parti
je réfléchi et
ça me rappelle le mec qui va au
commissariat et qui dit pour ma femme
qui avait disparu vous pouvez arrêter
les recherches et le flic lui dit elle
est revenue il dit non j'ai réfléchi
[Rires]
ce qui est important c'est que il est
parti à temps il a il a il a pris une
décision au bon moment et il est parti
élégamment c'est-à-dire que il se
comporté loyalement et Dieudonné
à un moment est-ce que un humoriste ou
le monde de l'humour ou le monde peut
donner une chance à Dieudonné ou bien
comme l'a dit Jean-Marie c'est plus
possible parce qu'il a voulu je connais
Jean-Marie c'est une bonne patte et
Jean-Marie s'est dit moi je crois au
voilà j'ai envie de lui donner une
seconde ou une troisième une quatrième
chance et puis après tu tous les gens
t'ont dit tu as vu ce qu'il a fait il a
voilà tu as parlé de Faurisson specte
c'est ce que disait aussi Laurent
Ruquier ici c'est vrai que Gilles c'est
une question que pas mal de gens se pose
absolument alors pour moi il a fait de
l'antisémitisme son fond de commerce
donc c'est impossible c'est pour ça que
ça m'a choqué quand j'ai appris que vous
vouliez quand même que vous aviez l'idée
de lui accorder ce pardon pour moi c'est
pas possible mais d'autres pensent
l'inverse moi je pense que son fond de
commerce c'est pas forcément
l'antisémitisme sauf fond de commerce et
la clandestinité c'est-à-dire qu'il a
réussi le compris d'être un humoriste ou
on court pour aller le voir quand je dis
on sait pas forcément moi au cours pour
aller le voir dans la campénéité c'est à
dire qu'il donne des rendez-vous
on se le dit entre nous et c'est devenu
la conséquence c'est devenu l'humoriste
de la clandestinité
d'être rentré dans ce jeu là bien sûr
mais Emmanuel juste rappeler un truc
c'est que il y a une petite différence
entre les gens médiatisés la presse
l'escalade toutes ces choses qui
t'arrivent sur la gueule dans une
seconde et tu te dis comment est-ce que
je suis aussi puni aussi fort et des
choses intimes qui arrivent dans ta vie
donc moi je rappelle que j'ai pardonné
l'assassin de de mon père et je ne peux
pas vous dire d'où ça vient
mais une chose est sûre c'est ce mec il
est arrivé la nuit
mon père avait rien pour se défendre il
avait un couteau de chasse comme ça il a
les ardé donc le corps de mon père d'une
douzaine de coups de couteau très
profond et puis que j'ai vu les mains
pleines de sang de mon père qui descend
l'escalier il arrive jusqu'à la porte
pour essayer de sortir et là il prend
une carabine il lui met le pied sur le
dos et il lui met un coup de carabine
dans la nuque pour le finir et bien
comment je peux vous expliquer que j'ai
pardonné de tout mon coeur
à ce mec-là
c'est comme ça c'est très fort le mec il
s'est livré à la police il était
repentant et donc j'ai accepté
de lui pardonner complètement parce que
le pardon c'est encore une fois c'est la
fin du match c'est terminé sinon bah tu
continues toute ma vie tu sais comme nos
amis les Corses qui pour un âne ou un
puits
depuis 29 générations
[Rires]
je t'aime et tu sais que j'ai toujours
été là pour toi et je le saurai toujours
voilà parce que tu es quelqu'un que
j'aime et si je baise un membre de ta
famille avec grand plaisir